this is ring an innocent smart doorbell
with a camera connected to the internet
owned by Amazon that promised security
Peace of Mind convenience it promised to
reduce crime in neighborhoods safety
nothing could go wrong right
well as it turns out ring is hiding a
dirty little secret that they don't want
you to know about Amazon may have handed
over your home surveillance video to
police without giving you a heads up
this is just crazy in new documents
Amazon admitting it gave footage from
ring doorbell cameras to law enforcement
nearly a dozen times this year without
the consent of users and we have a few
privacy issues related to security
cameras to talk about the first involves
the ring camera they have announced
according to the Washington Post that
they terminated a few employees for
abusing access to people's video data
here's something you might not want to
hear though if you own a ring doorbell
camera system Amazon might be spying on
you a Executives and Engineers
reportedly have highly privileged access
to live feeds and cameras inside
customer homes
all it takes is an email address in
privacy watch the popular doorbell
cameras ring are raising privacy
concerns across the country ring is
owned by Amazon and a new partnership
called the neighborhood watch program
has more than 400 law enforcement
agencies potentially using the security
footage that means police can have
access to customers videos right now if
you have a ring doorbell installed you
are being spied on and Amazon knows
exactly what kind of power it has on his
hands this is the largest corporate
owned surveillance Network America has
ever seen and Amazon has made secret
deals with big brother to share your
footage without your permission 1.4
million ring doorbells were sold in 2021
alone that is a lot of cameras connected
to the cloud these cameras see who comes
and goes it records the faces of
visitors the license plates of the cars
parked in your driveway or streets the
times you leave home income back
personal conversations you have around
your home information that can be used
against you in ways you can never
imagine and the beauty of all this is
unlike China where the Chinese
government has to manually install the
world's largest surveillance Network in
the west we have capitalism so instead
of the government forcing surveillance
equipment down people's throats Western
citizens are happily buying and
installing other surveillance equipment
ourselves from Smart TVs to Smart
speakers to Smart doorbells we in the
west are terrified when we hear about
things like China's social criticism but
over here we're willfully building the
exact same things except ours is
controlled by privately owned Tech
Giants that answer to no one and these
Tech Giants pitched the same promise the
Chinese government does Paradise on
earth a place where you are safe A place
where everything is convenient but the
end result will be the exact same as
China absolute control
except in our case will be led into
submission not with a whip but by our
own design
as Loki once said the unspoken truth of
humanity is that you crave subjugation
my name is Jake Tran and we make
documentaries on money power war and
crimes so that you can see the world for
what it really is a giant game of
acquiring power you can't get out of
this game either way so instead of being
a victim why not learn to be a better
player your parents teachers friends
Society will never teach you any of this
so we're going to stay dangerous and
this is great yet another step towards a
dystopian future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Mega corporations like Amazon are
becoming so powerful that they rival the
feudal Lords of medieval times Lords
were the wealthy Elite that owned land
back in the day but lucky for you you
too can now become a Lord with
established titles if you're not
familiar with established titles it
allows you to buy approximately one
square foot of land in Scotland for just
under fifty dollars and what's great
about owning Lane of Scotland is that
there's an oz Scottish tradition where
land owners are called lards and ladies
that way you can put that your lord on
your credit cards plane tickets dating
profile or on other places to be clear
it's not an official lordship but it's
still pretty cool your certificate will
feature a unique plot number for your
plot of land in Scotland and if you do
this right away you can actually get
your plot of land right next to mine so
we will conquer Scotland together these
make a fun unique last minute gift that
nobody else will think of getting so you
will really stand out and there's an
exclusive sale going on for viewers of
this channel where you'll get 10 off any
purchase when you go to established
titles.com Jake Tran and use code Jake
Tran with the link below so pause the
video and become a lore today by go into
established house.com and using Code
Jake Tran with the link below thanks to
established titles for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
in 2018 ring entered another very
special partnership a partnership with
none other than America's law
enforcement why would the cops want to
do business with a company that sells
smart doorbells simple surveillance
ring has video and audio footage of
millions of people's homes and streets
all across America it is a dream come
true for Big Brother ring was a massive
civilian installed surveillance Network
that would cover some of the most
crime-ridden neighborhoods in the
country it was another brilliant way to
spy on American citizens right after
Amazon's acquisition ring and the police
started having a very close relationship
so much so that by 2021 ring had
partnered with over 2 000 law
enforcement and fire departments all
over the U.S and it seems like they're
just getting started officially the
police need the permission of the
doorbell's owner or a search warrant to
view the footage ring records but
luckily ring allows for some pretty
convenient exceptions to that rule
Amazon will send video footage to police
whenever they want without your
permission as long as the ring camera
catches something suspicious that
suggests someone's life is or may have
been in danger
so in the case of an emergency cops
don't need permission to watch and use
any of the footage that doorbell
recorded they don't have to wait for
pesky search warrants or convince owners
to cooperate that's just too much
bureaucracy lives could be at stake
after all
so instead the police get all these
private videos and conversations
recorded by ring cameras on a silver
platter all in the name of your safety
of course this definitely won't be a
slippery slope another local homeowner I
spoke with says she has no problem with
Amazon shooting her video over to police
without telling her I'll feel good about
it I'll be glad to help if it was a
crime in my neighborhood I would be glad
if they turned it in so you wouldn't
feel like that was an invasion of your
privacy no not really understandably
this unprecedented power to spy has some
people worried what if they use this
surveillance Network for let's say less
urgent situations what if the camera
catches harmless Behavior cops can
misconstrue as illegal or dangerous
what if it catches people saying or
doing things that seem suspicious
because it lacks context what if someone
standing on their doorstep and wishing
their neighbor would shrivel up and die
could suddenly be used as proof of
Criminal Intent all of these private
personal moments that could be used
against you in ways you could never
imagine are being cemented inside an
Amazon server somewhere all in the name
of safety and convenience
scratching the surface of Ring's
problems in 2018 ring introduced a new
feature called Neighbors basically it's
an app where people can upload videos of
suspicious Behavior crimes pretty much
everything that's going on around their
homes and all the other people nearby
that are also on the app get
notifications about these suspicious
activities it's kind of like big text
version of neighborhood watch but in
this case American citizens aren't the
ones who benefit the most from this app
no the real winners are ring and the
police because every last one of those
neighbors app users just turned their
doorbells into snitches sure the idea
could definitely stop crime but the
potential for abuse is just as strong
ring is essentially building the largest
corporate-owned surveillance Network
America has ever seen they are turning
doorbells into personal Spies spies that
can see and hear everything and here's
the kicker thanks to the small print in
rings contracts they can share people's
private footage with the police in an
emergency without any legal trouble
[Music]
the ring cameras record everything all
the time apparently the answer is no the
ring camera needs to get triggered by
some kind of movement but once a Ring's
motion detector gets triggered it
records everything
every doorbell press gets logged every
motion the camera detects gets stored
the video the audio even the zooming
gets recorded and the ring doorbell can
hear everything from up to 25 feet away
so not only could random people like
bikers or delivery guys trigger the ring
camera they could also have their
conversations recorded without knowing
it
family may be having a private
conversation in their living room
if the ring camera is activated their
conversation isn't private anymore
everything gets recorded and goes
straight to one of Ring's servers which
are conveniently unencrypted of course
and if these recordings end up in the
wrong hands no one knows what may happen
next
footage could be used for blackmailing
stalking or other criminal activities it
could be used to put the owner on some
kind of secret watch list because he
said something provocative or
unpatriotic
the craziest part ring doorbells do have
an option to turn on end-to-end
encryption if encryption was activated
everything ring cameras record would be
useless to US law enforcement but
neither ring nor the police would be
able to watch or listen to private
conversations or videos anymore
but obviously that would be a really big
pain in the butt if you're trying to spy
on everyone
according to them encryption and
restricted access to all that precious
footage would kill opportunities for the
company and make it less valuable
so Amazon decided to turn off the
encryption mode by default
and as you can probably guess most
customers don't even know that
encrypting it is even an option which
means ring and the police can keep
spying on people as they see fit
so you have the largest corporate owned
surveillance Network in America where
all the footage is unencrypted and
ridiculously easy to access nothing
could go wrong right
thank you
even though ring quickly became the
leader of the smart doorbell industry
they struggled with something that was
at the core of their business object
recognition
and for a company that makes secret
deals with the police it would probably
be a good idea for their cameras to know
the difference between a masked criminal
and your neighbor's dog but back then
Ring's cameras just weren't at that
level yet sometimes their cameras
couldn't even determine if they were
looking at a tree a dog or the delivery
guy
users often complained that they were
receiving alerts on their phones even
though nothing was happening around
their houses ring knew they had to get
their image recognition software to the
next level so the company hired a bunch
of data operators in Ukraine probably
because they're way cheaper over there
and gave them a clear Mission teach our
doorbell object recognition ASAP
but even though technology has advanced
quite a bit object recognition is still
a tedious process Ring's data operators
have to manually tag and label each
object one after another so one day the
software can learn to do it on its own
but in order to do that you would have
to give these Ukrainian data operators a
lot of real video footage to label as
examples it's not enough to label just
10 videos and hope the AI is good to go
no you have to go through that process a
ridiculous amount of times with
thousands of different videos and
objects and where do you get all that
footage from from your customers of
course
so Ring's leadership actually gave the
company's Ukraine team of operators
unlimited access to every single video
created by every single ring camera
around the world
they said it was to ensure they had
enough real footage to train the
software was it unethical to do that
without asking for permission maybe did
it violate people's privacy sure did
ring tell their customers about this no
suddenly a bunch of strangers across the
world had access to everything ring
doorbells recorded every single video
and audio file from every ring device
around world and not only did they have
access to the video footage of outdoor
areas no no no they could also see what
was going on inside people's homes they
could see everything
they could hear everything from every
single ring customer
what's up homie I still see you the data
operators even showed each other videos
they were working on people firing guns
people stealing or doing certain
passionate things people like to do in
their spare time it was a violation of
people's privacy at its finest and not
only could The Operators watch the
videos they could be downloaded and
shared with just a few clicks
you were a professional blackmailer you
would get a job as one of these data
operators it was a gold mine
and to make matters worse the trail of
data exposure didn't end in Ukraine ring
also provided Executives and engineers
in the U.S with exclusive access
all they needed was a ring customer's
email address with that they could log
in and see the live feeds from the
cameras inside and outside their
Target's home whenever they wanted
[Music]
20th century we were blessed with two
incredible dystopian novels George
Orwell's 1984 and Aldous huxley's Brave
New World
1984 painted a grim world where the
populace was ruled by force by an iron
fist Aldous huxley's Brave New World
painted a different kind of dystopia a
dystopia not repressed by force or
fascism but by Pleasure by designer
drugs mindless entertainment and the
latest and greatest technology to keep
your life safe and convenient
China is definitely more of the 1984
variety but the West we're definitely on
our way to A Brave New World ring is
just one smart home accessory take a
look around you right now and count up
how many microphones how many cameras
you have in every corner of your life in
your living room in your bedroom at your
front door in your high-tech car at your
workplace and you'll see a foreshadowing
of what's to come
[Music]
Amazon and ring may be spying on people
every single day but average citizens
aren't the only ones who should be
careful even powerful CEOs and
billionaires should be careful about
what they say and who they surround
themselves with
because not too long ago a group of
powerful people felt a little too
comfortable around everyone's favorite
Private Island owner every jepsdean for
years he used his money and influence to
collect dirt on the world's most
powerful people using underaged girls
and the footage he collected was of
Great Value to him because every single
time he got in trouble with the law he
would be magically let free until one
day his secret protectors the people
keeping him safe from jail turned their
back on him
we all know what happened then
[Music]
but talking about the details of
Epstein's operation and his suspicious
death would definitely get any public
video demonetized on YouTube which is
why we've released a private documentary
on the man who didn't kill himself going
over all the sick details available only
to members of this Channel and so far
people have been loving the documentary
all you have to do to get access to the
video on every jepstein and all the
other documentary length videos that are
too controversial too dark too risky to
post publicly is click the join button
below once you sign up you'll get
exclusive access to our latest
documentary on the connection between
Victoria's Secret and jebstein among
many others these are the things they
should be teaching you in University
about how the world works but unlike
University you get all of this for just
five dollars a month and there's a
refund policy too unlike most YouTube
memberships
so if you join and you don't think it's
worth it email tell us within your first
month of joining and we will personally
refund you for your first month after
your first month there is no refund so
scroll down and hit that join button now
all right
do you guys have Smart products in your
home I try to avoid them as much as I
can you can call me paranoid or whatever
but that's just my preference let me
know what you guys do in the comments
below but if you're new here this is one
of the biggest channels on YouTube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime so if you enjoyed this video we
make multiple videos just like this one
every single week for free so click that
subscribe button below remember you can
always dislike unsubscribe and leaving
your best hit comments whenever you want
so you have nothing to lose and
everything to gain you can follow me on
Instagram but that's going to wrap it up
thanks for being part of the Washington
Club stay dangerous out there and I will
see you guys in the next one foreign
[Music]